if you're lucky no matter what life
hands you you can always count on your
closest friends to be there the trailer
for season two of HBO Max's Sex and the
City Revival series and just like that
just dropped
it's a big step up for Chase and me yeah
things are heating up between Miranda
and Che we didn't come back to be boring
we came back to to throw these
characters into new situations and let
them follow their hearts and just like
that Aiden's back I realized
some things are better left in the past
[Music]
but maybe
not everything
[Music]
they're keeping secrets this long on
Wednesday the streaming service
announced the show will return in June
and the sneak peek shows Miranda played
by Cynthia Nixon cozying up to Che
played by Sarah Ramirez of course fans
will recall in season one Miranda told
Steve that she wanted a divorce so she
could pursue a relationship with Che he
this really happening are you asking me
for a divorce this is really happening
really it was very bold we're not going
to be Treading Water we're actually
going to be be sailing into completely
unchartered Waters you look especially
pretty tonight no thank you and you look
especially whatever acceptable
non-polarizing gender positive
compliment you feel comfortable
you are a lot of fun there's definitely
a lot to take in between these two and
the possibilities are endless the first
season ended with Miranda moving to LA
with Che I'm following my heart here and
trying not to second-guess myself the
way I usually would you didn't like us
because we were
and while we'll just have to wait and
see how things play out between Miranda
and Shea it's a big step up for Jay and
me season two will also bring back Sex
in the City fan favorite Aiden and just
like that I realized some things are
better left in the past
[Music]
but maybe
not everything
[Music]
Aiden played by John Corbett appeared in
the original series if you don't want to
marry me right now
you'll never want to marry me
that's not true I think it is and the
movie sequel Sex in the City too this is
the best Mirage that I've ever had
back in September Sarah Jessica Parker
confirmed to E.T Aiden's back two is
about resilience and rebound and
laughter and more Aiden could be could
be well you know I mean I can't be I
can't be like cryptic about it
I know I'm very excited and on Wednesday
as JP shared the new trailer to
Instagram writing in part to all of you
our beloved audience who keep these
stories alive this one's for you was it
coming together after a very complicated
and terrifying large amount of time it
just felt
appropriate somehow and it gave us a lot
of opportunities as you know to make the
family larger and start telling news
stories
[Music]